Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my new  Superman video
there was a huge announcement you all
probably saw in your feeds Henry Cavill is leaving
the role like James Gunn made an announcement to
all explain what's going on because in the
same breath they said that they're starting
to make a new Superman movie at the beginning of
next year but it's not going to be Henry Cavill
Superman it's going to be during a completely
different part of the timeline there's no one
on this planet that can stop me I'll explain
how this fits into all of James Gunn's plans
because obviously there's going to be a bunch of
recastings they're basically reimagining the DC
Universe it's basically like a rebirth type of
event like you saw in the comics a couple years
ago but this is Henry cavill's statement that
he literally just made and James Gunn posted his
response like right at the same time so clearly
it was coordinated like okay we're both post our
statements about this at the same time Henry
Cavill says I've just had a meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Safran and it's sad news everyone I
will after all not be returning to Superman after
being told by the studio to announce my return
back in October that part actually confirms that
as of October recently he was coming back to do
Man of Steel I wanted to wait until the weekend
was over before posting this uh because I wanted
to give you all a chance to watch Black Adam
but now that plenty of you have I wanted to
make it official that I am back as Superman
and the image you see on this post and what
you saw in Black Adam are just a very small
taste of things to come so uh there's a lot to
be thankful for and I'll get to that in time but
I want to thank you guys most of all thank you
for your support and thank you for your patience
I promise it will be rewarded so there were a
lot of plans right before James Gunn was hired
once the paperwork on that dried then James Gunn
and his partner came up with a plan to reboot DC
and that's when all the changes started being
made like I just did a video about Wonder Woman
3 being canceled Patty Jenkins is basically off
the project Gal Gadot might be recast she might
come back Jason Momoa is definitely done as
Aquaman after Aquaman 2 even though he might
come back as Lobo and we know that Ezra Miller
is definitely out my name is Ezra Miller and I
am criminally excited to be a part of the Justice
League but then Henry Cavill goes on to say prior
to their hire talking about James Gunn's hire
this news isn't the easiest but that's life The
Changing of the Guard is something that happens
talking about the big reboot at DC with new
actors coming on he says I respect that James and
Peter have a universe to build and I wish them all
involved with the new universe the best of luck in
the happiest of Fortunes he's being a real champ
about all this because you have to hand it to
him he just left his role at The Witcher Netflix
because it sounds like he was planning for for a
big push of Superman at DC he goes on to say for
those who have been at my side through the years
we can mourn for a bit and then we must remember
Superman is still around everything he stands for
still exists in the examples he sets for us are
still there my turn to where the cape has passed
but what Superman stands for never will and it's
been a fun ride with you all onwards and upwards
so everyone pour one out for Henry Cavill he's
a totally awesome dude wish him the best of luck
time for him to call Kevin feige back like who's
he going to be playing at Marvel now that he's
totally free because spoiler everybody fan casting
him is a new version of Hyperion because there's
been rumors about them doing Squadron Supreme
in the MCU soon if you don't know who Hyperion
is it's basically Marvel's version of Superman
but a darker version of Superman Hyperion isn't
Eternal like the eternals move we saw a little
while ago like a Celestial robot basically but he
has the same backstory as Superman his planet was
destroyed and he was fired through space to planet
Earth so making all the Marvel casting jokes
now like everyone a fan casting Henry cavill's
different Marvel characters James Gunn's statement
actually says that Henry Cavill might come back
in the future as Superman this is what he says
about it and he talks about the new Superman movie
that they're starting to make at the beginning of
next year he starts by saying Peter and I have
a DC slate ready to go which is basically like
their next 10-year plan for DC building up to
a new Justice League movie their version of a
DC rebirth plan in the movies he goes on to say
which we couldn't be more over the moon about
we'll be able to share some exciting information
about our first projects at the beginning of next
year meaning that they have a bunch of projects
that they'll announce in January and February that
includes DC movies and future DC HBO shows like
the big budget HBO series they've been working
on but then he says among those on the Slate
is Superman like a new Superman movie In the
initial stages our story will be focusing on an
earlier part of Superman's life so the character
will not be played by Henry Cavill so that's his
official statement like no it's not going to be
Henry Cavill coming back for Man of Steel too but
Superman is a huge priority for them and when they
say it's taking place earlier in Superman's
timeline I think that what they're saying is
it's more like the Man of Steel movie where it
did An Origin story for the character really
really early in his career like Man of Steel was
literally An Origin story we saw him becoming the
character for the first time I think what they're
gonna do is they're gonna do what Matt Reeves did
for the Batman movie but with Superman like it'll
be Superman year two the way that the Batman movie
with Robert Pattinson was Batman year two so
it won't be a complete retelling of the origin
story the same way that Matt Raves didn't want to
do the death of the Wayne's again like the movie
referenced Batman's parents death but we'd seen
the Wayne's die so many times that it's like we're
gonna do that one more time we're just gonna skip
over that how many times do you want to see those
pearls and what they're doing is they're actually
doing all these separate Justice League characters
the way they should have done it originally and
slowly build them up to the next Justice League
movie so that by the time they do the next Justice
League like Justice League rebirth whatever they
want to call it you've lived with the characters
for several years the same way that Marvel did it
back in phase one with the first Avengers movie
I understood that reference Marvel Phase 1 in the
DC Universe DC Phase One but phase one of a brand
new timeline everybody wondering now what they're
going to do at the end of that flash movie to try
and set this up or if they'll just cold turkey
reboot the franchise oh by the way it's rebooted
now this new movie you're gonna come and see in
a couple years gonna be totally fresh if they
really wanted to they could retune the end of
The Flash movie just to set that up like oh by
the way we're gonna reboot everything and use
Flashpoint to do it because they were already
kind of doing that with the movie to begin with
before all the crazy Ezra Miller stuff started
happening James Gunn goes on to say but we just
had a great meeting with Henry talk about Henry
Cavill and we're big fans we talked about a number
of exciting possibilities to work together in the
future meaning that they're leaving the door open
for Henry Cavill to come back in the future of DC
movies like this isn't absolutely the end for him
but it is meant to be the end of him as the main
version of Superman like that'll be whoever this
new person they cast is as the younger version of
the character and that'll be the one that you see
in all the big crossovers most the time James
Gunn did confirm that he is the person who who
is writing the new Superman movie which makes me
feel a little bit better about the situation like
I'm really bummed out that Henry Cavill is leaving
that really sucks really really wanted to see Man
of Steel too but I am a little bit more hyped for
James Gunn's take on a fresh version of Superman
if it's going to be a completely fresh slate of
the DC Universe I made the comparison a while
ago that he was actually doing a version of what
he did at the beginning of the new Suicide Squad
movie where he killed off a bunch of the original
characters from that first Suicide Squad movie
but acknowledged some of the continuity and did
something fresh with the characters like he kind
of made it his own but he acknowledged what
came before him getting rid of a lot of the
Justice League actors you could think as being a
version of that and let me know Henry Cavill comes
back how do you want him to come back like do you
want it to be a Flash Forward situation where he's
still playing his version of Superman but he's
like the far future version of whoever this new
Superman is going to be or is it just going to be
a Multiverse twist where he says that like all the
Zack Snyder era of Justice League characters in
those movies took place in a different Universe
which is probably the easier way to go he here's
where we get to the Batman of it all too because
a lot of people are like what about Ben Affleck
Batman James Gunn literally said is part of the
same thread talking about the new Superman movie
recasting Henry Cavill that they had just met with
Ben Affleck yesterday as I'm posting this video
so like very very recently about directing one
of the new DC movies he already said he was going
to stop playing Batman a while ago he did shoot a
cameo scene for Aquaman too I don't know if they
got rid of that because of what James Gunn did
recently because they shot that before James Gunn
was hired to reboot DC movies so like up to last
month the plan for DC movies path forward was
completely different now if Ben Affleck were to
direct DC movie it probably wouldn't be the Batman
2 or the Batman franchise because Matt Reeves is
directing all the Batman sequels if he does say
yes they might say something about it early next
year you also probably saw the news about Robert
Pattinson's Batman early this morning because one
of the news outlets variety reported that they
were actually going to make him the new main
version in the Justice League crossovers but then
like literally right after a variety posted that
James Gunn jumped done it and said absolutely
not that is totally false there's no way we're
going to make batteries cross over his Batman
with our Justice League DC movies interesting um
no Matt Reeves also chimed in right after that
too on James gun post saying oh thank you so
much that's great news obviously he was very
tongue-in-cheek like he knew what James Gunn's
plans were because Matt Reeves had already had
meetings with him about the future of DC what
they said prior is that James Gunn's plans to
completely rework reboot everything at DC do
not include the Batman with Robert Pattinson
Matt Reeves franchise in the Joaquin Phoenix
Joker franchise everything else like only those
two things seem like they're off limits they'll
both be allowed to continue to exist in their own
universes at least for now but for the younger
people that are watching this best example is
recasting Spider-Man so many times in such a quick
time period like you go back to the early 2000s
we have Toby Maguire they don't make Spider-Man
4 they recast Andrew Garfield he doesn't make
it to Amazing Spider-Man 3 even though he's back
now within a very quick time period they wind
up recasting to the Tom Holland MCU version of
Spider-Man they make the deal with Sony and it
winds up being a completely different thing for
several years until Spider-Man no way home when
they do their big Multiverse movie where Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield come back and they
completely re-contextualize their movies saying
that oh no it's all still Canon because of the
Multiverse now so I wouldn't be surprised if
they do something similar in the future with
this new DC reboot of the movies we're in the
new continuity now that James Gunn is creating
this DC rebirth timeline he recasts a bunch of
the actors starts fresh does younger versions
of the characters but then they build up to
a crisis on infinite Earths in the movies like
their version of Avengers Infinity War Avengers
end game or Avengers 5 Revengers 6 Secret Wars
whatever you want to call it and that's when
you bring Henry Cavill Ben Affleck all the other
old actors back to play the characters again in a
Multiverse context so I think that's part of what
James Gunn was talking about when he said that
he would potentially come back in the future like
Henry Cavill will come back we've been talking to
him about doing something in the future together
now just because James Gunn said that he's the
person who's been writing this new Superman movie
with the younger version of the character doesn't
mean that he'll be the one to direct I mean it's
always possible but if you remember when James
Gunn initially went to direct The Suicide Squad
movie he met with Warner Brothers they basically
told him he could do any character anything that
he wanted with any part of the continuity he said
during their first meeting they initially pitched
him doing a new Superman movie but obviously it
was a big question as to which Superman it would
be everyone let me know in the comments though
who do you want to play this younger version
of Superman if he's still going to be like a
late 20-something actor but it'll be like Superman
year two and who do you want to direct the movie
assuming that it probably won't be a Zack Snyder
like I don't think that he's going to bring back
Zack Snyder otherwise they would have announced
that a while ago like I said in my other recent
DC videos this is a developing situation they'll
continue to make more announcements James Gunn
even said in his post that they would announce
their new slate for like the next 10 years early
next year maybe not the entire slate but at
least a couple of the next upcoming movies
after next year's actual slate there'll be four DC
movies coming out next year and that's not going
to change they'll still release those the rock
is sweating bullets now hoping that he doesn't
get recast too because it sounds like he had
a lot of plans he brought Henry Cavill with
press purpose that he was going to reignite the
DC Universe in related news if you want to know
what Zack Snyder was going to do with Justice
League 2 I did like a full breakdown of that
because he revealed the entire plot of the movie
and it is nuts like it is huge click here to learn
about that and click here for my Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!